hello everyone welcome to part four of
open ale
i'm going to show you some positional
and directional stuff
so the big changes are i've made a file
called top down
and it is just a top down opengl
grid like effect and what i've done is
i've added
two players there's a blue and a red
player the red
player will be playing a sound this
sci-fi
sound and it's set to looping is true
and its position is its position
so each little cell in this grid
is one space or one opengl
unit and as our listener we have set
the two nation to tl
inverse distance clamped and if we just
take a look at
that and the main programmer's guide
it shows the formula and it also tells
us the default mode is that
there are a whole bunch of different
models and so we set that we set the
location
to our location starting out which is
just at zero we are starting our player
at zero
and the orientation of our player
matters too this is what direction we
are facing
now our up vector is z1
so we're essentially if you use the
right hand rule
and look at your hand wow it's like you
know gun
thing pointer and then this this would
be your x so
x is to the right negative x to the left
we're essentially looking straight down
on this except this is up
so we're rotated like so we have x to
the right we have y
going up and we're starting at 0 0
and the other player is going to be at
max max of grid which is way up here
so it's kind of like the top right
quadrant of a grid
is what this grid is and you'll see
as we move towards and away from
the sound it will change now it'll seem
pretty drastic
because when we're changing direction
when we change direction
it is a very sudden shift of
a 180 from looking up to looking down
for a 90 degree turn
looking left to right so we're not
having gradual turn
like this is set for we are just doing
this sound in a grid but
this way you'll be able to hear the
difference
and be able to think of each of these uh
grid spaces as one unit so you might
have to adjust
the two nation according to your
game engine and how you how you want the
sounds to fall off
alright so let's go ahead and hit play
now the one thing to note about this
that's kind of important
is you can't actually see the direction
of the player in the visual it's just a
blue square
but the last direction you pressed is
what direction you're facing
so i need to update that and make it
like some kind of pointer or triangle or
something
that rotates but i just haven't got
around to that so here it is
running and we're starting out as this
blue square
looking up so we can hear the sound
sort of on our right and here in my
headphone i don't really hear it on the
left at all
if we move to the yeah
so if we move to the right we'll
suddenly be
facing right and
the sound should be on our left so i'm
going to move right
now since we're facing right the sound
is on our left
and now if i press up and move to this
square i'll be facing up so it should be
on our right again
and so on so i will be able to dance
around through here
and once i get really close or right on
top of it
right on top of it it's all over both
sides but let's start moving away to the
left
and we should hear it fade off behind us
pretty directly
yeah there we go so that's it directly
behind and let's come towards it so i'm
going to press right and once i start
going off to the sides
it starts uh bouncing between left and
right depending on which direction i'm
facing
i'm changing direction a lot as you can
see it works pretty well
and all the way over here would be like
what one two three
four five six seven eight nine nine
units away i think
or maybe it calculates to end because
it's diagonal i'm not really sure
but somewhere around nine and ten opengl
units
away reduces the volume pretty
significantly
and i assume that is full max volume
just being right on top of it
we're both at the exact same position
mathematically
okay so i'll just show you those
functions i added
real quick uh let's go sound effects
okay so on our sound device i added a
couple new functions
there is a set of two nation we just
want to set that
to make sure it's picking up you um i'm
not sure if you have to set this
or to engage but it's a good idea too
we have set location to just set our
little rule
location and we use that anytime we move
we have set orientation
we also use this anytime we move this
sets
you're looking at direction so this is
usually a front vector
and this one is an up vector so it can
kind of tell if you're hell
head is tilted or whatnot i'm we're just
keeping it
the same the whole time with the z as
the up
vector and i'm not using set gain but
it's there and i've added some getters
too
and if you look at these implementations
they are just calling to the
al stuff oh
that orientation that's enough how it's
supposed to be
and sends the data on over same with the
set location
i'm not doing any error checking here
because based on what you're passing in
it should be impossible for it to fail
but in general we want some error
checking i just didn't
go through all the extra time of
structuring that all out too
i just kind of made it do the thing but
it should be pretty safe the way it is
i did set a it was pretty easy to make a
little guard on the uh
donation because there's only certain
viable models so we just make sure
whatever key they pass in
is between those models and if it's not
we just throw
because we don't want to continue oh
let's see
yeah all those okay in the sci-fi sound
there's set looping set position and
just play
now this is just part of a sound effects
player
so you want one player per source uh
generally
this one can play different buffers you
just don't want to overlap the buffers
like you don't want to switch it while
one's playing because that'll cause some
bugs um so it if you want a bunch of
different sound effects
often you want a player for each but if
they are sound effects that cannot
overlap anyway but they're different and
i guess you could swap in between the
same player
and as our main which that runs the game
we're just using that main loop we're
set in a run condition
it's a function we call in grid we're
adding to on begin
just anything we want to happen once at
the start
we have a couple things from the grid
game we have process map change and
init and on our
delta update we want to process the
player
it's delta because there is a timeout on
how fast you press the keys that way you
don't like zoom across the map a million
miles per hour
so that's really the only thing that is
needed
i did have an ai and at one point of the
little red square moving around and
doing things collecting stuff
but it was a little complicated with the
opengl so i left it out
i might add it in later if i'm so
enthused
and of course this is open source so
anyone is welcome to mess with it if you
want to add
any cool little thing that makes it
better that's
always good and on post update is just
what happens after all these delta
updates it's kind of like the
render time after everything's updated
and
the only thing we have is our render
scene function from grid game
and then we just call that main loop run
or yeah or return it even because it's
going to
pass whatever it is should return a zero
only if one of these functions returns
something else that it could
uh return something else okay i feel
like there's something else i should
show that i haven't shown
well i guess you can go check out this
codes on github link will be below
and yeah that's it for this episode
i hope you love uh learned how to do
this setting of the
things and understanding the distance
and open the l
a l a little bit the orientation and
stuff i'm aware that this could
be a whole lot more worked up but
yeah i don't exactly want to get into
talking about
all the opengl stuff too much as it's
not the focus of this video
basically i just pulled some basics of
uh
loading a basic shader and stuff when
you write the code i just reused stuff
from other places already had it
because it's pretty easy to find a good
source just to
get basic started with opengl if you're
not sure well there's a few of them out
there
the opengl tutorial dash tutorial.org
one is pretty nice
and there's learn opengl all of them get
you started pretty well
another thing that is important to
mention is the sound you use does have
to be a mono
sound you can use audacity to help you
figure that out
so what you can do is if you get a file
show you with this one
i'm using this sci-fi drone file that
came from opengameart.org
if you drag it in you'll see what it
looks like and as you can see that's a
mono
sound if for example you have another
sound let's try this one
that's a mono sound if you see two sound
waves right next to each other
it's probably not mono so i think maybe
one of these is a stereo sound
yeah so that is a stereo sound there if
you try to do
the whole orientating and it just
doesn't work at all when it should be
check your sound because these stereo
sounds just do not work
but if you don't want it to have any
distance a tuning and just be like an
ambiance or something
you want to do it as a stereo sound for
that reason
also you have to be careful because
yeah you just want to make sure you're
using all mono sounds
when you're doing distant stuff and so
probably all your sound effects or
speeches or whatever that your
characters are given that are
orientated you want to have a mono and
that's pretty easy to do with audacity
here
basically all you do is you uh do what i
did here just open it up
drag it in there you can click on this
little drop down at the top and go to
split stereo to mono that was right here
where it says the name of it
and you can just x one of them out and
then file
export i usually do hog those seem to
work well with open ale
but yeah let's go ahead and do it so i'm
just gonna
annotate this one with mono so that's
the one we'll want to load
if we want to do effects with this spell
so that's pretty important to know
when you're doing this and messing with
directional stuff
leave a comment below what should we do
next time what should i cover
next i feel like i've actually covered
most of this
library there's a lot of little niche
things but
i could make one little final demo of
like being in a 3d world and it all
working
that might be a good last video let me
know what you guys think below
matt from code tekken tutorials over and
out appreciate you guys watching
and quite a journey we did hit over 2k
subs which is amazing i i don't know
what to think
it's a lot of people so that's that's
awesome it's just
it's cool to see and i appreciate all
you guys
and i'm always uh listening if there's
any certain thing i'm not sure what
content to make anymore i know a lot of
people are here for blender a lot are
here for the coding stuff
a lot of here for the talks so
trying to figure all that out a little
bit i appreciate your guys's
support going through this i wish you
all the best during these trying times
see you next time